we're here with Alessa militina ELISA
you just finished your first year at Law
School at UPenn was that good to get
that semester behind you so you can
focus on chess now definitely last year
the championships were held in April and
it really wasn't helpful that I still
had to do schoolwork while I was playing
so I'm very happy that I'm finally free
to focus on chess I just took my last
law school final on Friday so I'm about
to get that over with why do you think
so many chess players become lawyers so
many I wouldn't say that a lot of chess
player is going for loss didn't they
make good lawyers I think they
definitely would there are certain
subjects that share certain areas with
chess in terms of strategy in terms of
thinking analytically and we know your
academics are probably pretty good
considering you finish college and with
it two years yes it was in two years but
with law school it's a bit of a
different story because they have a very
tight curve so I don't know my academics
are that great in your so for players I
don't play a lot of tournaments when
they play in a big one like this is it
possible to you know do a crash course
study session for chess or do you have
to stay in shape the whole time to be
successful I guess we'll find out but I
do try and keep up with it just to solve
puzzles look at games though
being very serious nothing that demands
a lot of opening preparation so I think
that may be very telling because I know
a lot of the other players here are
professionals and they keep up with
dairy and that's something that I
definitely don't have in this year do
you feel like in this tournament that
you have a lot of experience with the
same women and it's gonna be who
surprises who first or how much of an
element is that when all the women seem
to seemingly have played each other so
many times in the past I think
definitely you probably see a lot of the
women try and vary their openings and
try and go for some surprises because we
have been playing each other a lot so it
um
this probably is also the only time each
year we've been playing together and I
think throughout the year we all played
very different people so we all come in
with different experiences what are your
thoughts on having a separate tournament
for women only why do you feel like it's
needed in the chess world I don't know
if it's needed but I recognize that it
may be necessary in terms of the
business perspective and women are of
course for you to try and play in the
open section you know I'm sure well
we'll see a woman get in there someday
great well good luck trying to win your
first u.s. women's chess championship
ELISA and we wish you well on your
comeback to chest
thank you